spencer turnbull two seamen four-seam
fastball
can control the four-seam better throw
more strikes and locate
and he slices this one into left field
the base hit and it's gonna get
into the gap and gamma will tried into
second base with a lead off double a
good start especially
on that 02 pitch now the 1-2
slowly to short willy castro soft hands
out number one leads the brewers and
stolen bases with four
there goes yelich the throw from romine
is in time and they got him
what a throw by romine and scope
put the tag right on yelich another 3-2
on the ground jonathan scope awaits
excellent spencer turnbull and the
tigers get out of it back-to-back starts
for hauser against the same team that
presents its own set of challenges
it's a fourth time he's done that in his
career
and a good start for hauser he strikes
out the hot batter a pennant stretch and
has done well in his stops back in the
america league since
and another strikeout for hauser two in
a row
and a roller to arcia and it's gonna be
a nice
quick tidy one two three first inning
for adrian hauser first and second to
start out the third inning
the brewers are set up with the top of
the order coming up see if he can put
him away
right back to him they've got the man at
third
and the throw dug out of the dirt by
candelario for a sweet looking double
play
one five three double play you don't see
many of those
he loves it
that's good stuff you hold up who's got
it
oh wait is he running get one
they get the lead runner how about two
jonathan scope leads out for the tigers
no score bottom of the fourth
hit him he always worried right here the
hand area
he's holding that hand like it is numb
looks yeah
this ball just gets away and he starts
to hit we're talking about how important
he is to the tigers and he is
they're gonna they're gonna bring him
out miguel goes down to second base he's
there with two outs in a scoreless game
for willie castro turns on it and that
should be a fair ball and it is
they're going to hold up canola they're
going to wave cabrera home and he'll
trot home without a throw
one nothing tigers willie castro
continues to roll
corners in one away reaches out that's
gonna drop
rbi single for victor reyes christian
stewart trots home with the tigers
second run of the night
base is loaded two outs big opportunity
for the tigers to break open
a two-nothing game right back up the
middle
jamer candelario delivers again romine
is home
reyes scores big inning for the tigers
here in the fifth
base is loaded for jorge bonifacio
goes the other way that's gonna drop one
run is home
here comes candelario he's gonna score
bonifacio jumps on the first pitch
another two run singles
six nothing tigers here in the fifth
three double plays turned so far by the
tigers defense tonight here's the one
two swinging a miss
that's an important out there for
gregory soto
here's the two two swung on and missed
back-to-back punch-outs by soto after
giving up a couple of singles
the 2-2 wave and a miss and soto strikes
out the side here in the seventh
six nothing tigers are in the seventh
inning the two two
swinging a fly ball right field way back
and right
and go on a home run jamer candelario
launches to right man his bat has been
sizzling for over a month now home run
number five it's a four
rbi night two run shot here in the
seventh makes it eight nothing
getting an opportunity to come back
tonight
[Applause]
nicoderius and did he make the play
he did what a job by urias over at third
base
good job by aureus and a good job by
jericho jose cisnero
hoping to make it just a formality here
in the ninth
to right center bonifacio hustling over
puts it away hira tags
moves up to third but there's one away
here in the ninth
jeff going to left field it falls in for
a base hit and the brewers are able to
finally get on the board after
knocking on the door this one hit well
this will get
into left field a base hit another run
coming home for milwaukee goldbach stops
at
second base so the brewers get their
second run here
the 2-1 to center derrick hill drifting
back
he's got room and there's two outs
and this one into center field falls in
for a base hit
and another run coming home for
milwaukee here in the ninth inning it's
an eight to three game
popped it up left side foul territory
paredes
has room tigers win it 8-3
they make the most of their eight hits
they pull to within a game of the 500
mark